Welfare payments.
When people hear that
most of us think about poor people lined up
for food stamps and rent subsidies.
but America’s biggest welfare recipients
are politically connected corporations,
like America’s sugar industry.
This small group of rich men gets
billions of dollars in taxpayer subsidies.
And yet, they have the nerve to run ads saying we don’t.
American farmers don’t get subsidy checks.
And America’s multi billion dollar sugar program?
It costs taxpayers nothing.
Nothing!
Their spokesmen go on TV to say:
We are a no cost program, no cost to the taxpayer.
That's absolutely bogus, taxpayers do pay the cost.
Ross Marchand of the Taxpayer Protection Alliance
points out that sugar producers get bailouts
by us taxpayers whenever sugar prices
fall below a certain level.
The government will buy sugar
from the sugar processors
and sell it to ethanol producers
at a below market rate.
And who's paying the difference?
Who's footing the bill? U.S. taxpayers.
I wanted to interview representatives
of big sugar about their sweet deal.
But they would not talk to me.
So, I’ll present their deceptive arguments
from their ads and public statements.
Depending on others for food
never works out as expected.
Big Sugar has the nerve to use images from WWII
to suggest we’ll have food shortages
if government doesn’t give them a special deal.
Does America really want to give foreign countries
control over its food?
Oh, please!
Imports increase our supply of food.
There are no import restrictions on most other foods
and we have ample supplies of them.
Big Sugar also says:
American farmers don’t get subsidy checks
they get loans that are repaid with interest.
Has to be repaid with interest!
Repaid in what?  Sugar?
They actually are allowed to repay in sugar if prices fall
and taxpayers must pay the difference.
But sugar prices rarely do fall
because America imposes quotas on
domestic production.
And limits how much sugar we can import.
These are Stalin-style price controls
and supply controls and it does not help anyone.
Well, it helps big sugar!
The politically-connected owners
of the sugar companies collect
several billion extra dollars - from you.
At roughly 3 billion a year.
Creighton University economist Diana Thomas explains
why congress never repeals the sugar industry’s scam.
The multi-billion dollar handout costs each of us
maybe 10 or 20 dollars.
we’re not going to go to Washington
to lobby against that but -
each American sugar farmer made
roughly 3 million dollars a year extra.
So each of them is willing to spend
a lot of time and money
making sure the law stays that way.
In addition, Americans must pay billions more for food
because Congress restricts imports
of cheaper sugar from places like Brazil and India.
I am prepared to get rid of the sugar program tomorrow
if the countries we compete against get rid of theirs.
Big sugar’s politicians say,
since other countries foolishly subsidize sugar,
we must retaliate.
It basically allows our sugar industry to compete
with other countries that are heavily subsidized
It's only fair to our sugar producers who
don't get subsidized who can't compete with
these subsidized countries.
Is it fair for customers
to pay double the world rate for sugar?
Is it fair for taxpayers to have to bail out
a handful of super rich
super-connected sugar processors?
No.
So crony capitalists host
“sweet benefit dinners” while all of us pay more.
♪ Domino Sugar makes America smile ♪
The Americans least likely to smile are candy makers.
They're the ones hurt most.
There's one candy cane producer left in Ohio.
That's absolutely ridiculous.
And look at all those jobs.
People from Akron they need these jobs.
20,000 jobs a year lost, says this study.
While big sugar pays for ads that say:
Sugar has nothing to hide, that’s because it’s all natural.
These products - they are bad for us!
Maybe it's good we eat less because they cost more.
Well not all sugar products look like that.
I mean,  just look at bread.
Bread and beer, yogurt, ketchup and cereal...
The fact that sugar is in everything means that
healthy and unhealthy products alike
are going to cost more.
And all that money is going to that handful
of rich politically-connected growers and processors.
So every time you buy anything made of sugar,
you’re getting ripped off by a clever group
of businessmen who got your politicians
to pass special laws for sugar.
I wish more of you went to Washington, D.C.
with a message for big sugar and big government -
Get out of my life!